a principios del siglo 20 los físicos se
encontraban confundidos porque la luz
que pensaban era una onda en ciertos
experimentos se comportaba como si fuera
una partícula por ejemplo se realizó un
experimento llamado el efecto
fotoeléctrico en donde se envía un rayo
de luz sobre un metal y arrancará
electrones de dicho metal si es que la
luz tiene energía suficiente pero si
tratamos de explicar esto con mecánica
de ondas tendremos el resultado
equivocado y sólo recurriendo a cierta
descripción de la luz en la que está
solo puede entregar energía en paquetes
discretos fue que einstein pudo
describir cómo funciona este efecto
fotoeléctrico y predecir los resultados
reales que se obtuvieron en el
laboratorio en otras palabras la luz
solamente entrega energía en cierta
cantidad específica igual a algo llamado
la constante de planck multiplicado por
la frecuencia de la luz es decir que
toda toda esta energía completa al
electrón
nada de energía el electrón nunca le da
algo a medias le da todo o nada pero
esto confundía a las personas ya que
pensaban que ya habíamos establecido que
la luz era una onda y pensamos esto
porque si hacemos pasar la luz a través
de una doble ranura si la luz fuera una
partícula o un grupo de partículas
esperaríamos que estas partículas
pasaran ya sea por el agujero de arriba
y viéramos un punto brillante aquí o
pasarán por el agujero de abajo y nos
dieran un punto brillante acá pero lo
que medimos en realidad cuando hacemos
este experimento con la luz es que la
luz se disfraza por ambos agujeros se
superpone y nos deja un patrón de
difracción en la pantalla de manera que
en lugar de tener dos puntos brillantes
nos da un patrón de interferencias
constructivas y destructivas que solo
podemos obtener si el rayo de luz pasará
por ambas ranuras y se superpusiera como
lo harían dos ondas que pasarán por dos
agujeros al otro lado de esta doble
ranura
por lo que este experimento demostró que
la luz se comporta como una onda pero el
efecto fotoeléctrico muestra que la luz
se comporta como una partícula y esto
seguía pasando en diversos experimentos
en algunos la luz se comportaba como
onda y en otros la luz se comporta como
partícula
finalmente los físicos se resignaron al
hecho de que la luz tiene propiedades
tanto de onda como de partícula
dependiendo del experimento realizado
así estaban las cosas cuando en 1924 un
joven físico francés un brillante físico
francés llamado louis debré aunque
pareciera que deberíamos pronunciarlo
libro y que es como siempre lo digo en
mi mente pero sé que así no se debe
pronunciar lo busqué y encontré que se
pronuncia más como louis kébreau y
quitamos esto y lo reemplazamos con una
y en nuestra mente y decimos louis debré
en 1924
louis de pro y escribió un artículo en
el que hizo algo que nadie
había hecho todo el mundo estaba ocupado
pensando en la luz y su comportamiento
como onda y como partícula
dependiendo del experimento tweeter hoy
dijo que tal si el electrón que salió
volando aquí si la luz que pensamos era
una onda y que actúa como partícula
qué tal si los electrones que pensamos
son partículas pudieran comportarse como
ondas
en otras palabras quizá tengan una
longitud de onda asociada él trataba de
sintetizar ambas ideas en un solo marco
de trabajo general para describir tanto
el comportamiento cuántico de la luz es
decir las partículas de luz y las
partículas las que de por si pensamos
que son partículas quizás también
pudieran comportarse como ondas es decir
las partículas de luz y las partículas
las que de por si pensamos que son
partículas quizá también pudieran
comportarse como ondas él decía que
quizá todo en el universo puede
comportarse como onda y como partícula
dependiendo del experimento que se
realice
él incluso dijo cuál podría ser esta
longitud de onda se les llama la
longitud de onda de the bride y se
define así y de hecho es un postulado él
no demostró esto motivó la idea pero le
dejó a los físicos experimentales la
tarea de demostrar la él dijo que la
longitud de onda de las cosas que
asociamos con la materia a veces a estas
se les llama ondas de materia pero la
longitud de onda de digamos un electrón
es igual a la constante de planck
dividida entre el momento de dicho
electrón y por qué eligió la constante
de planck
por cierto si no están familiarizados
con la constante de planck es como lo
dice su nombre una constante y tiene
siempre el mismo valor de 6.6 26 por 10
a la menos 34
jules segundo es realmente pequeña es
una constante que fue descubierta con
otros experimentos como el del efecto
fotoeléctrico y el experimento original
del cuerpo negro con el que trabajaba
plank
se llama constante de planck y aparece
en casi toda la física moderna y la
mecánica cuántica y cómo es que se le
ocurrió esto a louis de ebro y porque la
constante de planck sobre el momento
bueno porque las personas ya conocían
por la luz que la longitud de onda de un
rayo de luz también es igual a la
constante de planck dividida entre el
momento de los fotones en ese rayo de
luz por lo que el nombre de estas
partículas de luz se llaman fotones los
dibujos localizados en el espacio pero
no crean que es así como son piensen en
ellos como que solamente depositan su
energía en puñados o en grupos no tienen
que estar necesariamente en un punto en
el espacio en un momento en particular
esta imagen no es muy fiel al concepto
pero no supe de qué otra forma
representar gráficamente el que los
fotones depositan solamente su energía
en grupos así que no se tomen muy en
serio este dibujo pero las personas ya
habían descubierto a esta relación por
los fotones y quizás
a ustedes les moleste algo y me digan a
ver un momento cómo es posible que los
fotones tengan momento no tiene ninguna
masa yo sé que el momento es masa por
velocidad y si la masa de la luz es cero
no significa que el momento también será
cero y si es así no haría infinita a
esta longitud de onda si estuviéramos
trabajando con la mecánica clásica sin
duda así sería pero resulta que esto no
se cumple cuando viajamos cerca de la
velocidad de la luz ya que de forma
simultánea a todos estos descubrimientos
en física cuántica einstein se dio
cuenta de que esto no se cumple cuando
las cosas se mueven con una rapidez
cercana a la de la luz la fórmula real
luce así la energía al cuadrado es igual
a la masa invariante o masa propia o
masa en reposo al cuadrado multiplicada
por la velocidad de la luz a la cuarta
potencia más el momento de la partícula
al cuadrado multiplicado por la
velocidad de la luz al cuadrado
esta es una mejor relación entre el
momento y la energía esto se cumple en
la relatividad especial y al usarla
podemos deducir esta otra fórmula para
la longitud de onda de la luz en
términos de su momento y la deducción no
es difícil vamos a hacerla aquí pues
sólo nos llevará un momento la luz no
tiene masa propia eso lo sabemos no
tiene masa invariante por lo que este
término es igual a cero tenemos la
fórmula para la energía de la luz que es
h por f por lo que al cuadrado es al
cuadrado por efe al cuadrado
efe es la frecuencia de la luz esto es
igual al momento de la luz al cuadrado
por la velocidad de la luz al cuadrado
saco la raíz cuadrada en ambos lados
para quitar todos estos cuadrados y me
queda h por efe igual al momento por c y
si reacomodamos esto dividiendo a ambos
lados entre el momento me queda h entre
p igual a y dividido a ambos lados entre
la frecuencia y me queda igual a la
velocidad de la luz entre la frecuencia
pero
la velocidad de la luz / la frecuencia
es la longitud de onda y sabemos esto
porque la rapidez de una onda es la
longitud de onda por la frecuencia así
que si despejamos la longitud de onda
nos queda igual a la rapidez de la onda
entre la frecuencia y para la luz la
rapidez de la onda es la velocidad de la
luz así que la velocidad de la luz / la
frecuencia es la longitud de onda lo que
nos da esta relación de aquí así que las
personas ya sabían de esto y de broggi
sugirió que la misma relación funciona
con las partículas de materia como los
protones electrones y neutrones pensamos
que son partículas pero quizá también se
comporten como ondas y quizá ustedes aún
no estén convencidos de esto y se
pregunten qué es lo que esto significa
el que una partícula se comporte también
como una onda y sin ni siquiera hacer lo
que esto significa como podría siquiera
aprobar esto pues lo probamos de la
misma forma que probamos como los
fotones de luz podían tener una longitud
de onda
probamos con un experimento que muestra
las propiedades de onda es decir tomen
estos electrones y lancen los por una
doble ranura pues si la luz se puede
comportar como una onda al hacerla pasar
por una doble ranura entonces los
electrones si tienen comportamiento como
el de una onda deberían mostrar este
comportamiento al hacerlos pasar por la
doble ranura y esto es lo que hicieron
las personas hubo un experimento de
davidson y gamer en donde tomaron los
electrones y los lanzaron hacia una
ranura doble si los electrones hubieran
creado dos mansiones brillantes justo
detrás de las ranuras sabríamos que no
tienen un comportamiento de onda y de
broggi estaría equivocado pero esto no
fue lo que descubrieron davidson y gamer
realizaron este experimento lo que no
fue fácil porque la longitud de onda de
estos electrones es realmente pequeña
tuvieron que usar estructuras atómicas
para crear esta doble ranura en un
experimento interesante que les
recomiendo que busquen
ileana al respecto ya que
la gente sigue usando este experimento
llamado difracción de electrones en
pocas palabras ellos realizaron este
experimento hicieron pasar electrones
por acá y que creen que pasó pues que
obtuvieron este patrón de difracción que
se da con el comportamiento de una onda
cuando esto ocurrió d'hebron ganó su
premio nobel ya que mostró que él estaba
en lo correcto las partículas de materia
pueden tener el comportamiento de una
onda de la misma forma que lo tiene la
luz lo cual es una hermosa síntesis
entre dos áreas de la física materia y
luz que resulta no son tan diferentes
después de todo muchas personas piensan
que lo único que hizo de broe
fue tomar esta ecuación ya conocida y
renunciar la para partículas de materia
pero él no hizo solamente esto puedes
leer su artículo es muy interesante y
podrán darse cuenta de que él hizo más
que esto su artículo es impresionante y
está bellamente escrito así pues aunque
de broggi hizo más cosas es por esto por
lo que la gente lo reconoce mejor
para enfatizar la importancia de esto
antes de esto las personas tenían muchas
fórmulas e ideas en la mecánica cuántica
que no podían comprender pero después de
este punto después de este parteaguas se
comenzó a pensar en las partículas como
si fueran las fórmulas previas que
funcionaban sin que supiéramos cómo o
por qué ahora podían ser demostradas en
otras palabras pueden tomar esta fórmula
esta idea de ebro y mostrar por qué
funciona el modelo atómico de boro y
poco después de la publicación del
artículo de the brain schrödinger llegó
y preparó el escenario para todo lo
demás de la física cuántica y sus ideas
tuvieron mucha influencia de broggi en
resumen la luz puede tener propiedades
de onda o de partícula
dependiendo del experimento y lo mismo
ocurre con los electrones la longitud de
onda asociada con estos electrones o
cualquier partícula de materia puede
encontrarse tomando la constante de
planck y dividirla entre el momento de
la
particular y esta longitud de onda puede
probarse en experimentos en donde los
electrones muestran un comportamiento
tipo onda y esta fórmula representa
correctamente la longitud de onda
asociada con el patrón de difracción que
surge de este comportamiento de onda